وزير الداخليه التركيه اعلن اعتقاله منفذ
انفجار اسطنبول ويلتهم حزب العمال
الكردستاني بالوقوف ورائه
حزب التضامن الديمقراطيه الاحوازيه اياد
دول العسكريين العرب في صفوف القوات
المسلحه الايرانيه الى الانشتاق
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه تكشف عن قرب فرض عقوبه على شبكه
للمشتريات العسكريه لروسيا
شيفون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره اخباريه من العربيه
اعلن وزير الداخليه التركيه سليمان سولو
اعتقال الشخص الذي وضع قنبله في شارع
الاستقلال متهما حزب العمال الكردستاني
بالمسؤوليه عن الاعتداء الذي اسفر عن سته
قتلى على الاقل يوم الاحد في اسطنبول
واوضح وزير الداخليه التركي ان جميع القتل
السته فيلم الانفجار مواطنون التراك
وكان رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ونائبه فؤاد
اخطائي قال في وقت سابق ان امراه هي
المسؤوله عن الاعتداء وهو ما لم يتحدث عنه
وزير الداخليه فجر اليوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعرابات وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن ادانه
المملكه باشد العبارات تفجير الارهابيه
الذي استهدف منطقه تقسيم واسطه اسطنبول
واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان
المملكه تقف مع تركيا ضد هذا العمل الجبان
معربه عن تعازيها لذوي الضحايا والتمنيات
بالشفاء العاجل للمصابين
دعا عضو المكتب السياسي لحزب التضامن
الديمقراطيه الاحوازيه حافظه الفاضلي دعا
في بيان له العسكريين في صفوف القوات
المسلحه الايرانيه الى الانشقاق معربا عن
استعداد الحزب لمساعده المنشقين على
الوصول الى مناطق امنه خارجه ايران
مباشر
[موسيقى]
قبل فوات الاوان خاصه من اولاد الذين لم
تلطخ ايديهم بالدماء وحضورهم بالاماكن ان
يساهم في تشكيل نواب [__] رادعه ضد الظلم
والتعسف وعدم تكرار مجازر ارتكبت بحقتنا
عام 1979 من هنا نرفع هذا النداء العاجل
الى كل ابنائنا الاحوازيين المنضويين في
القوات المسلحه الايرانيه
والشرطه
وباقي الاجهزه والدوائر المدنيه بانها بان
حان الوقت للانشقاق من هذا النظام
وين التحاق بركوب هذه الثوره كما ندعوكم
للتواصل معنا بشان اي تسريبات بامكانها ان
تمنع تنفيذ اي مخطط خبيث ضد ابناء شعبنا
او باقي المجتمع الايراني بكافه العرقيه
والدينيه والمذهبيه
الرصاص والغاز المسير للدموع لتفريق
المحتاجين الذين تجمعوا حوله مستشفي طهران
حيث يرقد الناشط حسين رونقي وكان شقيق
شقيقه حسن ارونقي اعلن ان قوه الامن
الايرانيه تحاول نقل شقيقه حسين رونقي من
مستشفى دي الى مكان مجهول
[موسيقى]
السعوديه
يا سلام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
امين امين
[موسيقى]
المنشاوي الهامستر
القضاء الايرانيه امس حكما بالاعدام على
شخص
ضلوعه في اعمال شغب خلال الاحتجاجات
المستمره في البلاد وابقى موقع ميزان اون
لاين التابع للسلطه القضائيه ويعتبر هذا
الحكم اول عقوبه القصوى تصدر عقب
الاحتجاجات التي عقبتها وفاه ماسا ميمي
اثناء احتجازها لدى شرطه الاخلاق في طهران
واوردها الموقع احكام بالسجن بحق خمسه
متهمين اخرين على صلاه بالاحتجاجات
في الايطار ذاته وجه القضاء الايراني على
اتهامه لنحوي 800 متظاهر جديد في ثلاث
محافظات على خلفيه الاحتجاجات ووفق ارقام
القضاء الايراني تم توجيه الاتهام الى
اكثر من 2100 شخص نصفهم في طهران منذ بدء
الاحتجاجات وافاد موقعه ميزان التابع
للقضاء الايراني بان
164 متظاهرا سيحاكمون اعتبارا من الخميس
المقبل بتهم اثاره الشغب واضاف الموقع ان
المحتاجين سيحاكمون بيتهم التامر ضد
الدوله والتحريض على القتل والدعايه ضد
النظام واستهداف قوى الامن واشار موقعه
ميزان التابع للقضاء الايراني الى ان
التهامه الموجهه للمحتاجين قد تصلوا
عقوبتها الى الاعدام
قالت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جانت هيلين
ان الولايات المتحده ستفرض عقوبه جديده
على شبكه عابره للحدود
وشركات تعمل على شراء التقنيات العسكريه
للجهود الحربيه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
واضافه الى الصحفيين على هامش قمه مجموعه
العشرين في بالي باندونيسيا ان العقوبات
ستستهدف 14 فردا وثمانيه وعشرين كيانا
ولكنها رفضت الادلاء بتفاصيل عن اماكن
تواجدهم
قال الرئيس الاوكرانيه
ان المحققين اكتشفوا اكثر من 400 جريمه
حرب الروسيه وعثروا على جثث جنود
في عده اماكن بمنطقه خرسون
بالفعل اكثر من 400 جريمه حرب الروسيه
وعثر على جثث لمدنيين وعسكريين في منطقه
خرسون خلف الجيش الروسي ورائه الوحشيه
نفسها كما هو الحال في مناطق اخرى من
بلدنا حيث تمكن من الغزو سوف نقدم للعداله
كل قاتل دون ادنى
مراسل العربيه
اوكرانيا تستعد لتسيير اولى رحلاتها
منيكيف الى خيرسون بعد استعاده السيطره
عليه عليها عقب انسحاب القوات الروسيه
منها قبل ايام
[موسيقى]
اعتبرت وزاره وزاره
حقيقيا سيضع كيف في موقف قوه في حال جلوس
الطرفين الى طاوله المفاوضات
وينك
روسيا على تقديم مقترحات لاحلال السلامي
في اوكرانيا وقال ان اي مقترحا للسلام يجب
ان يراعي وحده وسيادته اوكرانيا معبرا عن
اسفه في الوقت ذاته لعدم حضور بوتين قمه
العشرين ومعربا عن امله في ان يغير رايه
في اللحظات الاخيره
مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
الرئيس الاندلسي يطالب المجتمعين في قمه
العشرين بخفض حده خطاباتهم ضد روسيا
حياكم الله دعى الرئيس الاندلسيه جوكو
ودودو عبى عدد من السياسيين الاندونيسيين
القاده الغربيين لخفض حداد خطاباتهم
المعاديه لروسيا في قمه مجموعه العشرين
وفقا لصحيفه بوليتكو يتعرض المسؤولون
الامريكيون والاوروبيون والاستراليون
واليابانيون لضغوط من نظرهم الاندونيسيين
ولا سيماها الرئيس الاندونيسي لاظهار
المرونه والتفكير في استخدام خطاب اقل حد
لضمان الموافقه موسكو على بيان بعد
الاجتماع
تحذير شديد الاحجار رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد القوات المسلحه السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهاني السياسيين بالابتعاد عن
الجيش ومحاولات التحرير مشيرا في كلمه
القاها في قاعده المريخات العسكريه الى
انقسام القوه السياسيه وغياب التوافق بين
الاطراف السودانيه يضر بالمؤسسات كافه
اسئله الكبرى تملا الفضاء السياسيه في
السودان هذه الايام عما يدور وراء
التفاهمات السياسيه بين العسكريين
والمدنيين والتي ترعاها الرباعيه تمهيدا
لبدايه لقاءات مباشره وغير مباشره اعلنت
الاليه الثلاثيه عزمها على انقاذها قريبا
موقف المكون العسكري جاء على لسان البرهان
في حديثه للقوات الخاصه بقاعده المرخيات
العمليه ابرز الرسائل القبول بوثيقه
المحامين كاساس للحل والتطلع لحكومه
كفاءات والقطع بان ليست هناك تسويه ثنائيه
هكذا قال البرهان
[موسيقى]
الجيش استغلاليته
رسائل البرهان تلقتها القوه السياسيه
الفاعله المجلس المركزي للحريه والتغيير
رحب بتصريحات البرهان ومضى فيما ذهب اليه
رئيس مجلس السياده بعدم وجود تسويه وانما
عمليه سياسيه تهدفوا لانهاء الوضع القائم
ليس هنالك عمليه سياسيه او اجراءات لانهاء
وضع قائم واقامه سلطه مدنيه تلبي تطلعات
الشعب السوداني هذه السلطه المدنيه يجب ان
تدعمها قاعده انتقال
والحريه والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه
بدورها ترفض التسويه الثنائيه كما ترفض
الاحتكاما الى وثيقه المحامين كاساس للحل
لو في اي حوار في اي وفاق يتم يتم مع كل
القوه السياسيه الموجوده في الدوله
السوداني سوداني وانا سوداني ما عنده الحق
انه يفرض عليه ورقه يجب نجلس كلنا مع بعض
ونضع الاوراق دي ونتناغش في كيف انه ممكن
نقدر نودي الدوله
بعض المراقبين يتسق مع بيان الاليه
الثلاثيه الاخيره وان الحل يجب ان يشمل
الجميع الرسائل هنا واضحه جدا انه التسويه
التسويه شامله وليست التسويه ثنائيه دستور
المحامين هو موقف ايجابي لكن في حدود
توضيحاتها زي ما بنقول ارسل سياسه السودان
يعني بتعديلاته الحاجه الثالثه
عبر الانتخابات
تقارب في الرؤى السياسيه مع بعض المكونات
وتباعد من الباطه هكذا تمضي الدينميكيه
العمليه السياسيه في السودان والتي لم
تتضح رؤيتها حتى الان نظرا للتباعد في
المواقف واسس الحلق محمد عثمان العربيه
الخرطوم
اعلن مسؤولون اوروبي ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يخططه لتشكيلي مهمه شراكه عسكريه مطلع
العام المقبل للمساعدات في تعزيز قوات
النيجر التي تقاتل المتطرفين يتزامن ذلك
مع اعاده الاتحاد الاوروبيه النظر في
الوجود العسكري في منطقه الساحل بعد سحب
جزء من افراد البعثه التدريبيه العسكريه
في مالي اردا على نشر مجموعه الروسيه بطلب
من المجلس العسكري
هكذا طويت صفحته وجود عسكريين فرنسي في
مالي ثم النيجر تباعا انسحاب طردته حملات
المناهضه لا بل كاريه للوجود العسكري
الفرنسي في المنطقه باسرها اطراف فاعله
جديده دخلت على خط العلاقات لعب دور في
تجيش مشاعر القاره السمراء ضد الفرنسيين
ما تسبب في طردهم روسيا تركيا ثم الصين
موسكو وبعد 30 عاما من فك الارتباط عقبا
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي عادت من جديد الى
التموقع في افريقيا هذه المره عبر مجموعه
فاغنر العسكريه الخاصه هو التي تضاعف
انتشار عدد عناصرها في السنوات الاخيره في
عدد من الدول الافريقيه في افريقيا طموح
تركي يتممدد حيث طورت انقره شبكه مكثفه من
العلاقات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والعسكريه
الى درجه اثارت قلق قوه اخرى مثل فرنسا اذ
استطاع التركيه من فتح اكبر قاعده عسكريه
لها في الصومال وتدريب نحو عشره الاف جنيه
واقامه شركات الاقتصاديه وعسكريه وامنيه
مع جيبوتي واثيوبيا مع محاولتها الدائمه
لسيطره على مدخل البحر الاحمر عن طريق
جيبوتي بحثا عن مصالحها الاستراتيجيه بكين
لا تغيب عن المشهد الافريقي حضورها
المتنامي يعكس اولوياتها من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
في ما قد يتعلق الامر بضمان تفوقها
التجاري وتنميتها الاقتصاديه
السباق نحو افريقيا نفوذ يتصاعد واخروا
يتراجع في ظل خوف من عدم استقرار يعصف
بالمنطقه ما يشكل مناخا خصبا للارهاب
وداعميه من شاكله داعش وغيره عصام عبد
السلام العربيه
تسبب التوثيق المدفوعه على تويتر بعد
اعلان
بمبلغ ثمانيه دولارات على الحساب دون
التحقق في هويه المستخدم تسبب في خسائر
كبيره لشركه تجاريه حيث قام مجموعه من
الناس بانتحال باسماء الشركات الكبرى
وشخصيات سياسيه بارزه عبر حسابات مزيفه
لكن موثقه في الوقت نفسه
قرار
على علامه التوثيق في تويتر وكسب الاموال
من المستخدمين انقلب راسا على عقب سيلون
من الحسابات المزيفه منتحله اسماء الشركات
التجاريه كبرى اجتاحتر وتسبب بفوض عارمه
في المنصه
الامثله كثيره حساب موثق في تويتر لاسم
شركه قليل الامريكيه للادويه بتغريده تفيد
بان الانسولين اصبح مجانا الان التغريده
هذه كلفت الشركه اكثر من 15 مليار دولار
وتراجع اسهميها بشكل حاد حساب مزيف للسبيس
اكس المملوكي من ماسك نفسه غرد عن عقودها
الحكميه المربحه بينما حساب مزيف لتسلى
غرد بدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا بعشره الاف
السياره وان سيارتي تسلا هي الاكثر تطورا
وقابله للانفجار
حسابات مزيفه اخرى انتشرت بشكل كبير على
سبيل المثال للحصر
كواحده باسم ابل غردت بمحاوله بيع الهواء
بالمعنى الحرفي واخرى لشركه بيبسي مغرده
ان كوكاكولا افضل منها بينما غرد منتحل
لشركه كوكاكولا ان الشركه هي الاولى في
التلوث الناتج عن البلاستيك لاربع سنوات
على التوالي
الحسابات المزيفه الموثقه طالت شخصيات
سياسيه كذلك كواحد لدينال ترامب بتغريدات
تقول ان الجو بايدن هو رجل وزعم جيد
وتغريده اخرى تفيد بان اوباما كان افضل
رئيس للولايات المتحده وتغريده ثالثه
لتحمله المسؤوليه لاحداث السادس من يناير
اي اعمال شغب الكبتل ثمانيه دولارات فقط
هي ثمنه توفيقي اي حساب على تويتر دون
التحقق من الهويه مبلغ زهيد ولكن سيتسبب
بالفوضى لمنصه تعاني اساسا من الفوضى رشا
خياط العربيه
قالت شركه تسلا الامريكيه لصناعه السيارات
انها ستساعد الشرطه الصينيه في التحقيق في
حادثه تصادم باحدى سياراتها من طراز واي
بعد ان افاد التقارير اعلاميه محليه بان
شخصين لقي حتفهما عندما فقد السائق
السيطره على السياره في اقليم في في اقليم
في جنوب الصين
[موسيقى]
اصدرت كلهم من ايطاليا واليونان و مالطا
وقبرص بيانا مشتركين اكدت فيه رفضها ان
تكون دول الدخول الاولى للمهاجرين غير
الشرعيه هي المحطات الوحيده الممكنه
لاستقبالهم واضافت الدول الاربعه في
بيانها ان عدد المهاجرين الذين تستقبلهم
بعض الدول الاوروبيه هو ضئيل قياسا بالعدد
الفعلي للوافدين غير الشرعيين الى اوروبا
وايات البيان على خلفيه الخلاف حول
الاتفاق الاوروبي
لمساعدتي طالب
[موسيقى]
في نهايه النشره هذا التذكرهم بابراج
العناوين
وزير الداخليه التركي يعلن اعتقال منافذ
انفجار اسطنبول وينتهي محزب العمال
الكردستاني بالوقوف ورائه
ان يدعو العسكريين العرب في صفوف القوات
المسلحه الايرانيه الى الانشقاق
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تكشف عن قرب فرض
عقوبات على شبكه للمشتريات العسكريه
لروسيا
القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]